hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead midseason finale
video a lot of crazy things happened not
in the way that I expected them to
though so in addition to everything
going bananas we needed to talk about
what's gonna be happening next as well
as the big post-credit scene it was
really cool but they actually used a lot
of these things to disseminate a lot of
information about the direction the
show's going real quick reminder in the
grand tradition of mid-season finales
I'm doubling the giveaway so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment but I'll
explain at the end of the video careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet but starting with
top five moments number five Rick runs
down agent Sitwell there is a certain
satisfaction and seeing Sitwell eat it
one more time on another show I'm sure
the actor that plays him in real life is
totally nice but he is such a douchebag
on screen and with all the rape that was
going around the hospital you have to
assume that he might have been in on
some of that creepiness too so good
riddance to him I just love the way they
build the momentum with that car chase
rick is like one of ridley scott's
aliens like he's right out of an alien
movie chasing down Sigourney Weaver only
the alien finally gets it at this time
seriously didn't you just love the way
they edited that just jumping back and
forth like you don't even see that it's
him you just see the knife slash the
Walker guts as he flies by but the
minute the car pulled into that alleyway
I just I knew I was like there's no way
he is not going to hit him with that car
he finished the job with the gun I would
have rather seen him just do it with the
car I just I love the imagery in this
episode between Rick revisiting his
heritage as an officer of the law and
these other cops at the hospital in the
last episode he was actually giving off
some of a shame by this episode he
seemed a little bit more reasonable I
think they just wanted to demarcate the
hospital versus the survivors like they
really wanted us to not like the
hospital people it would have been nicer
if they'd have played it a little more
ambiguously like made Rick a little bit
crazier and made the hospital people
like slightly less rapey
either way sit well may you rest in
peace you've done your job in another
show now he can go hail Hydra somewhere
else
I'm giving nine to ten odds that if he
shows up on another drama he gets killed
on that show too number four Beth and
Dawn versus rapey pants jr. yes that's
right there's more of them so did anyone
else see like this weird dawn thing
going on where like she was trying to
ship herself with Beth and Beth just was
not having any of it she's like hey we
are best friends let's share some booze
and let's kill officer McCrae pee
together
seriously how creepy are all the
policemen there I mean they want them to
seem unlikable so I think that's why
they included all this rape story like
they really wanted you to not like all
these people with the exception of Dawn
that they wanted her to be more on the
fence
it did give Beth the opportunity to have
that big win and finally push someone
down the elevator shaft I would have
rather Beth push them both down
but then she would have had to explain
to the other police officers who came
running what happened there are actually
some really interesting things that we
learned and Beth and Dawn scenes dawn
covered up
Beth killing the first officer McRae be
like she cleaned the jar up and the body
so she isn't all bad but she's very
clearly delusional but she still thinks
that there's rescue in sight all these
things that were just meant to humanized
Dawn's character like up to this point
she seemed like super crazy and she
seemed slightly less so after these
scenes with Beth but they really wanted
you to think about Rick whenever you
were thinking about dawn like these were
two sides of the same coin just like the
same deal with Shane like a long time
ago I told Shane went crazy and of
course just like Shane dawn also went
crazy number 3 Abraham's group comes
back to the church as predicted
Abraham's group finally met back up with
the survivors not quite the way I
expected but it just means that they can
all head to the next place together and
no I don't think they're going straight
to DC but I do think that's gonna come
up the map showed up at the end of the
episode in the post-credits scene so
clearly that is a destination but it
might not be the next destination it was
a great way to come in - like the way
they just crashed into frame literally
just because of who Abraham is and his
personality I wouldn't be surprised if
he wasn't trying to keep the walkers
from getting out like he was just I'm
gonna park it here and just happen to
run over all those walkers that would be
so funny he is so much fun when he's
being like dude Abraham crazy Abraham is
fun too but I feel like you can only
have one really crazy person in the
group at a time and Rick is the crazy
person right now although given the
events of the episode Daryl might be the
new crazy person maybe even Maggie -
actually you know what Maggie's gonna
take the crown Maggie will be the crazy
person for the next couple of episodes
she was kind of crazy to begin with but
in a fun way
number two Morgan post-credits scene so
lots of information about Morgan in this
scene he is just behind the group not
super far behind they didn't show a shot
of the leg in the grill but he was at
the school like I mean he basically
followed in their footsteps
I like the little shrine that he put out
I felt like that was for his son like he
was saying a little prayer for his son
and like that was part of his ritual
like he wasn't gonna eat that candy what
the map tells us is is that he was not
openly following Rick he didn't know
that they were still alive but now that
he does he probably will he'll probably
end up in DC so I'm guessing that we
might not see him with the survivors to
like the very end of season five if not
the beginning of season six but I think
that will happen we will get that moment
I'm actually kind of hoping that before
the end of the second half of the season
we actually get like a Morgan episode
just Morgan in an entire episode but I
don't know if that's in their budget
like they really only do that for like
the most special characters like for the
governor before they killed him and for
Beth ostensibly before they killed her
maybe if we do get a Morgan episode that
means that he's gonna die too that would
really suck or maybe he's gonna be the
Jesus character from the comics like
maybe they'll give him that storyline
like he'll show up and be a total badass
if people have read the comics just use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about
Jesus and my number one WTF moment of
course Beth totally bites it so of all
the people that could have died in this
episode Beth was at the top of the list
with Carol I could have taken it either
way I felt like the way they edited
things was a little confusing like they
skipped a couple of moments like Carol
was just awake and lucid in that
wheelchair where she had been comatose
moments before they didn't really
explain that too well Beth must have
just really jacked her up on meds or
they must have been keeping her under I
know a lot of people are really happy to
see Beth go but here's the thing that we
need to really talk about did Beth stab
her knowing that dawn would shoot her
did Beth kind of commit suicide as a way
to save Noah I will say yes I think that
she did it on purpose she knew that when
she stabbed her with the scissors she
would get shot like she would die she's
like I get it now I get that I have to
get you to kill me so that Noah can
leave she talked about it earlier in the
episode everyone uses everyone else so
Beth learned that she had to use dawn to
get what she wanted and what she wanted
was for Noah to be able to leave I think
that's what she meant when she said I
get it but let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think that Beth meant when
she said I get it and are you happy that
she died that's actually the big
question - are you happy that Beth is
gone and it wasn't Carol full disclosure
I do feel like Carol is the more poppy
character overall just in general I gave
the finale and a - not quite as good as
the mid-season finale last year but I
didn't expect them to do the exact same
thing so I give them a high five for not
trying to completely repeat it the first
thing that really comes to mind in this
episode aside from you know someone
really big dying is the way they used
the camera first during Rick's chase at
the beginning of the episode and then
second at the end of the episode with
the Dutch angles like there was a crazy
amount of Dutch angles for those that
don't know that's just when they tilt
the camera it just adds dramatic tension
to the scene if you don't do it too much
if you do it too much it gets a little
comical I felt like they kind of rode
the line like they almost did it a
little too much they just wanted to
imply that it was like the classic
gunslinger moment but hats off to the
cinematographers on Walking Dead for
shooting an amazing chase scene and an
amazing standoff the show really does
work like a classic Wild West story I
mean think about it like if you were in
the Wild West
you can shoot someone and not get
arrested you could kill someone and not
get arrested just because there's been
so much speculation about Beth and Carol
dying you know her actually dying wasn't
that much of a surprise so most of my
attention was on the way they use the
camera I wasn't super connected with the
Beth character Emily Kinney I thought
did a pretty good job for the way she
went out like she did get a couple
really good hero moments I feel like
they didn't give her character that much
to do in the last couple of seasons so
you can't totally blame her if he felt
her character wasn't that likeable I saw
a couple critics talking about something
that they called Walking Dead's problem
with women it had to do with the female
characters for the first couple of
seasons you know until they kind of
figured Carroll out and she became the
first of what is now like a group of
really badass women like look at Sasha
Maggie
Carol all them could probably fend for
themselves like just as well as any of
the men on the show it just really makes
things that much more interesting when
none of the characters are visibly
incredibly weak I mean everyone's kind
of breaking down inside emotionally
everyone's probably like a five-year-old
child Karl's like the voice of reason
now which actually means he's probably
next on the hit list it's like once you
gain wisdom on the show like you're
marked for death
Beth gained wisdom I get it now BAM
she's dead that should be like the
survival tip for Walking Dead if you
want to survive just be dumb as much as
went down at the church I felt like this
episode belonged to Rick and Beth and
they were definitely on their a-game
like if the episode had been quite so
uneven I would have given it a solid a
there's just like no way that they're
gonna be able to match that prison
battle from last season though and if
you give that an A then you have to give
this like slightly less than that so
that's why I gave it an a-minus on to
next season though are the second half
of the season very clearly they're just
hitting the road like it is going to be
a back half of the season on the road
going from place to place although there
is a certain place that supposedly
Robert Kirkman spoiled a long time ago
they're gonna change the name so it's
from the comics if you have read um just
please use spoiler tags you want to talk
about it I think there'll be at least
one big place before they get to
Washington DC at the end and I think
that that's well there go where that map
was gonna take them anyway on all great
episode but here's the details on the
giveaway so it's just basically a $20
Amazon gift card but because it's the
finale I'm doubling it so I'm gonna give
away to Amazon gift cards remember all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave a comment
I'll announce the winners of my Q&A
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and I will be doing a top 10 moments
from the first half of the season
I'll do that in at least by Tuesday
probably there's su some really exciting
stuff happening on TV this week so big
flash arrow crossover more Walking Dead
bonus videos coming so and feel free to
leave requests too for bonus videos for
Walking Dead it's coming back February
8th so it's not gonna be gone that long
and in case you haven't seen them yet I
have new mobile links up here if you're
watching on your mobile phone it's the
same as the links that I had over here
but you can click here for the Q&A that
I'll post tomorrow I'll be announcing
the giveaway winners then and you can
click here for my top 10 moments from
the first half of the season I'll post
that in a couple days until then I'll
just I'll point it to the Star Wars
trailer but I'll add the link a little
bit thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five we watch the
episode baby like ten sixteen times
you